[Music]
he dangled reparations and elevated
expectations but who could have foretold
how his decision would unfold well just
as I predicted on my other hit show
called the one plus four
grease bucket Gavin is a no on estate
640 billion dollar reparation scheme
that was cooked up by some whacked out
ass brain task force
evidently though he's still a yes on
applying hair gel with a putty knife
I wonder this could be an amazing
strategy on his part
this could be an amazing strategy on the
governor's party commissions a report
that the end is so hysterical that
there's nothing you can do about it and
then he could just kind of push it off
so nothing happens no there's no way
this is happening it's not possible it's
not possible wow that guy has brains and
quads
which means it's time for hot guy is
right again
Oh Daddy
hahaha
just hours after a prediction that would
make Nostradamus pee his breaches
Newsome publicly declined to support
reparations checks last night telling
Fox News digital that dealing with that
Legacy is about much more than cash
payments the reparations task force
independent findings and recommendations
are a milestone in our bipartisan effort
to advance Justice and promote healing
this work must continue
translation
sorry blacks no dice on the checks
damn I haven't seen someone that strung
along since I dumped Taylor Swift
[Laughter]
Tyrus G wonder why you went to me yeah
because you weren't here we talked about
it yesterday
we didn't onion you're here um yeah you
got to give it to Gavin very clever
white man
clever
I'm always clever there was no fiscal
feasal way to do yeah what they wanted
to do but we need to be this is where we
get caught up it didn't just end okay
this task force these people on it just
fleece taxpayers for millions of dollars
to come up with this idea that oh it
doesn't work one you have to prove who
was and there's not a lot of records
from slavery right and you got to figure
out who actually gets the money you
could be white now could have been black
then you could have been on the wrong
side of the fence that's right
interbreeding A lot of it look at me
look at me
anybody would curl hair in the audience
you need to check your family tree
reparations was never about money it was
about opportunity yeah and the reason
why it was 40 acres in a mule because at
the time the job of the day was farming
yeah so what a better way to get an
opportunity to build wealth pass it down
to your family and take care of yourself
reparations about opportunity and we
have that in this country my reparations
is right here keep your check there you
go well said cat
very clever Caucasian to convene a task
force and then let the insane plan come
forward and then punt
I would do the same thing would you
I just don't see how you can call it a
task force what's the task
[Laughter]
yeah they just sit around and come up
with stuff that would be nice if it were
possible but it's definitely not yeah
that's a job it is it is a taxpayers
that is a job and the people pay for you
to do that right and I'm sure they get a
lot of lunches too that was also a
catered meeting gala's yeah
there was a happy hour afterwards that
started at like 4 P.M
yeah it's because it's not possible at
all but it sucks because for me when I
have a meeting about I have to figure
out the thing that I was supposed to
figure out and he was like great job
everyone this is completely impossible
but I'm very proud of you like what yeah
I want that work environment yeah me too
well I mean we do we we kind of do our
own thing here where we talk about stuff
and get nothing done yeah you don't tell
a joke from one second no punch line
yeah well no I don't know I just don't
understand how this was a great job if
none of it's possible or maybe maybe
he's covering it for himself because
maybe he actually wasn't listening he
didn't read the report he was kind of
like I'm tired I don't feel like it and
then he read he was like what I think KT
that's a possibility but also he wants
to run for office he needed to push this
off his desk oh as fast as he could
because he's made managed to alienate
everybody right so he's he dangles the
reparations and now so many people think
oh I'm going to get a million point one
and a half million dollars for just
being somehow a defensive as you point
out who knows what the family tree is
and
a he got them mad because he's raised
their expectations when he said it
anybody with a brain starts doing the
math and says hundreds of billions of
dollars a trillion dollars I'm a
taxpayer in California I'm out of here
and so they've all left and they've gone
to other states and so now he's got
everybody mad the the people who pay the
taxes have left the people who think
they're going to get the money are not
going to get the money right and here's
Gavin news and thinking I'm going to
ride this right into the White House
because if Joe Biden doesn't make it I'm
standing by with my terrific plan where
I've been so good to everybody but you
know can you imagine he'll get
eviscerated no he can't he's between a
rock and a hard place a phrase I just
coined Joe
Joe I think what they did is they
replaced like reparations is another way
of saying damages and I'm sure that you
have been damaged in your life many
times from assorted people women
probably lots of women uh you'll
probably spend a lot of your uh Teenage
and childhood Alone
um
I imagine that there you feel like you
might deserve reparations I've broke
some hearts too Greg
um you mean at the heart store
no
did you have to pay for them because you
broke them what was the question
do you foresee that anything with
damages anything that damaged you can
get reparations because they're the same
thing aren't they you know Greg uh all
the things that have happened to me have
made me uh Stronger like when a woman
breaks my heart I'm stronger for it
that's why I refuse to exercise but
I'll say this if you're gonna cut me a
six or seven figure check I'll say I'm
black faster than Jimmy Kimmel
but that could be yeah
I'll be I'll be found out when they find
out I didn't vote for Joe Biden
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else